é
à quelques vérifications.
Olivier Bachand.
ERIN O'TOOLE, chef,
Parti conservateur du Canada
- On va augmenter les transferts
en santé dans une manière
stable, prévisible et sans
condition avec un montant
près de 60 milliards $.
- Est-ce que ça se traduira
vraiment par un financement
supplémentaire de 60 milliards
sur dix ans? Pas nécessairement.
La formule actuelle se base
sur la croissance économinique
et prévoit une augmentation
des transferts d'au moins
3 % par année.
Si la croissance économique
est faible, la hausse promise
par les conservateurs pourrait
représenter un gain
de 60 milliards $
pour les provinces.
Mais si elle est forte, le gain
pourrait être plus faible,
comparativement à la formule
actuelle.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, chef,
Parti libéral du Canada
- On a investi assez d'argent
pour qu'on soit en tête de liste
dans la planète en termes
de vaccination.
- Le Canada est-il parmi les
premiers? La réponse est oui.
67 % des Canadiens sont
complètement vaccinés. Le Canada
arrive au premier rang des pays
du G7 et au 10e rang mondial
en termes de vaccination.
JAGMEET SINGH, chef,
Nouveau Parti démocratique
- En six ans, vous avez le pire
bilan du G7.
- Le Canada est-il le seul pays
du G7 où les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre ont grimpé
dans les dernières années?
Oui, c'est vrai. Lorsque les
libéraux sont arrivés au pouvoir
en 2015, le Canada a rejeté
723 mégatonnes de gaz à effet
de serre. Quatre ans plus tard,
ce nombre grimpait
à 730 mégatonnes.
Les États-Unis, le Royaume-Uni,
l'Allemagne, la France, l'Italie
et le Japon ont tous réussi
à réduire leurs émissions
pendant cette période.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET, chef,
Bloc québécois
- après toutes ces années-là,
il n'a pas trouvé les moyens
de déployer rapidement
les ressources financières,
humaines et en infrastructures
pour qu'il y ait de l'eau
sur les communautés autochtones.
- C'est vrai. Les libéraux
ne sont pas parvenus à régler
tous les problèmes
d'approvisionnement en eau
potable dans les réserves
autochtones en cinq ans,
comme ils s'y étaient engagés.
109 avis à long terme concernant
la qualité de l'eau potable ont
été levé depuis depuis novembre
2015, mais il en reste
51 en vigueur.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, M